[Music]
i'm down
wait we're rolling we are rolling people
okay
but you want to tell raising stories
okay so i have a story crazy gay story
no
joke okay so there's a story here
a lovely lady okay no sorry what the
[ __ ]
you interrupted yourself so you're
ovulating
no lovely lazy if she's ovulating that's
what she said right
he thought of a lovely lady was
ovulating oh i'm
sorry i'm ovulating those are good bars
they actually ovulated lovely lately she
said that
okay i was like whoa okay i apologize
viewers anyway
this is the story there's this man who
is obsessed with photography
to the point that he named his three
sons
nikon cannon pentax no iso
no no i'm not canon i hope not
okay so you have canon correct fujifilm
canon and nikon are correct
there's one more oh panasonic sammy no
no sammy wait not pentax not bnh
was a printer i thought it was
definitely a printer but i guess they do
exactly
different countries maybe that's what
prints all his photos this takes place
in india i don't think he likes cameras
that much because he [ __ ] it up maybe
he loves copiers too
she's like epstein's got sick copiers
well okay so this is maybe his wife is
really
into cameras too because his wife is a
camera oh yeah
well yeah that could be that's she's
ovulating oh
my god ovulating uh obviously
i was trying to make it to make it sound
like obviously but it was horrible
okay so i suck you're adorable that was
adorable the way that you just owned it
like that was [ __ ] hilarious
okay so the like he his hat
his passion for photography is so out
there
that his home is shaped like a camera
oh my lord oh my god
his three son's name i love him how many
times does his wife
eye roll him a day that's what i want to
know or her how her eyes go
[Applause]
i feel like yeah
[Music]
i feel like no i feel like he
is the nicki of their marriage where one
day he's just like oh yeah i hired
contractors to make our house look like
a camera
that's true deal with it way to own it
what a supportive wife
i wonder if that freaking camera lens
goes
it does it does it takes a picture of
the wireless wait hold on i don't know
about the lens
but i do know that there is a flat like
does this flash thing or okay let me
play this video legit looks sick yeah
let me play this i like it
i'm with him it's like a polaroid one
true i don't want a big a big printout
to come out of that honey wow
[ __ ] cool man this man is living in
the future
i like that roll of film there too at
least he's got some passion sd card
yeah that that's the other thing it's a
canon and a nikon
it's all three names on it
yeah this is click
dude that made all the other properties
value go down for sure
you think so i would want to be his
neighbor
no it's a tourist attraction now you
know how many people [ __ ] congregate
there
yeah then you open up a store and the
valley goes up it's like venice beach
yeah but think about living there
[ __ ] crossing the street every time
at night to take a picture in front of
the house yeah
true welcome to my store and then you
can't walk around with your like window
like your blinds open at night
because then people are just gonna be
staring inside and wanting to see
it's his fault for being so cool then
you get an audience to see your naked
body
maybe you could sell you could sell a
lot right next to it that's what i'm
saying i just
go well i'm gonna create a camera store
next door yeah
yeah people that are touring around
there like you need some water with
bottled water oh that's pretty smart
cold water
a dollar water lots of mangoes there's
like two tables
cause it's like in the middle of nowhere
in india
i like a mango lassi oh yeah i haven't
had a mango last night
me too same they're so good i don't even
know what the [ __ ] that is i'll own it
it's uh [ __ ] it's amazing it's a mango
yogurt drink yeah almost like a moose
yeah i don't like sweet things there but
it's like tangy
yogurt but with mango um delicious
but it doesn't have that like thing that
yogurt has
because it's like yogurt with mango yeah
yeah but you drink it through a straw
you took it through a strawberry
but like yogurt blend it that's fine yes
you don't think that it'll be cool
if this whole block joins the party and
then they themed their house
like a film camera because of the
printer like for the
a projector the old school one yeah or
like it doesn't always have to be like
film it could just be people that are
really into their [ __ ] like
like a motorcycle house like like i'm
into cats so i put caviar
on my house is that you know that hello
kitty yeah
you know that kitty that says the
japanese one yeah
yeah yeah that's better because if it
was cameras then the whole time like
somebody's gonna get the shortage on the
stick and they're like oh man i gotta be
the [ __ ] white screen
like that's my house but they're the
polaroid like the projector the green
the green screen uh will be the green
screen
the green screen fine it's just a blank
roll it's a different picture every time
because we put different
pictures on the green screen what would
your dream house be
designed i want houses
i want a whole you can't break the rules
five five no no i said fine i said fine
i'll i'll i'll pick something it's just
he's buying time he's buying stuff
because i have to choose one it's got to
be something i really really like
careful i have my idea [ __ ] bamboo
what the [ __ ] you've never talked about
bamboo he only talks about mud hut
and [ __ ] cane sugar yeah i would
picture okay can i be joe because
i would be like mud hut right but then
once you go
in it expands it to this big mansion
house you don't even know it's there
underground mansion yeah he doesn't want
that well i want that
i want a swimming pool i want like trap
doors and [ __ ]
i want like a blink check how there's a
slide that goes down to the swimming
pool from a different room
i want that [ __ ] what's the house look
like on the outside i don't give a
normal ass house oh no it's a mud hut
but people don't know
yeah it's a mud hut yeah but i'm not
materialistic so that's why i said
bamboo dude
you should you should download animal
crossing and just make your bamboo
dreams come true
you can do it right now right now i want
it to be real i know
well that's as real as it can design it
and then you'll know what it looks like
bart what's yours i just want it to be a
mountain
that's it i got like like the hobbit's
house no no like a mount like like a
mountain
where you where you drive by it you
drive by and you can't even tell that
it's a mountain
and tell people that i know you can't
tell it's a mountain military base it's
like cheyenne mountain like the big
yeah it's like a straight up mountain
you don't even know but then if people
drive by or people know where it is when
they drive in the door opens and you get
to go in and it turns into like the bat
kid yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
sick bro that's cool i need my house to
be brighter than that though
i have windows on the back side uh not
the front side
or you have a skylight in the top of the
mountain it's a volcano you could have
smart glass
on the outside oh it's tight and then it
gets blurry yeah [ __ ]
that's how you like yeah i think so
it's like that guy that said he went in
an alien ship and like everything was
clear and like he's just raped yeah that
guy what's his name
i don't know bob lazarus no it wasn't
babazar
it was some other person what are you
talking about la bazaar bobazart didn't
go on the list
yes he did la bazaar he didn't fly in
the craft no he didn't fly it but he
went inside of it oh but someone flew in
it
oh [ __ ] oh dude i want my house to just
be all windows
that's it it's smart there's a church
impact privacy but everything else is
like natural light just flowing in
especially because now our the house
that we bought it gets almost no
natural light almost none is it because
of the other other houses in the world
it's facing the other side so the garage
gets all the sun
and so so it's facing the north yeah
isaac's room and the spare room they get
all the sun
but the living room where it matters
there's no sun you know where i spend
the most of my time
outside uh in my backyard in my garage
i have a um i got a map your backyard is
so nice it's nice isn't it never mind
but i gotta
i gotta i gotta get out of there when
it's sunset because that's when the uh
mosquito zombies come
yeah yeah but then when it's before that
i have a mat
and i just roll around there read some
books i get my laptop i can work out
there
it's nice we are the same person what
you like outside
then why did you get a house that has no
outside no it does it has a patio and i
made it all nice out there
i remember you sat there very nice
that's true but did we have hookah there
yeah yeah that's true we did it okay i'm
i'm lying you broke up in my living room
just next to me it's okay because we've
never been to your house
you [ __ ] you guys could come if you
want to yeah
right i don't want to usually invitation
is how like that's not how i roll
you know pat stayed at my house for like
a couple of weeks no
did he tell did he tell you he was going
to stay there well yeah because that's a
role
he was like hey uh can i quarantine i'm
like yeah here's my key
stay at my house it's tight yeah you
guys can borrow it
huh yeah he was gonna get invited
huh cause i don't like inviting people
he's having a conversation with himself
let him talk to him he says but then he
answers
i know let him talk to himself why are
you interrupting him
it's because i like that interrupting
his own conversation you don't know how
to talk out your thoughts
oh my god it's hilarious everyone's like
oh invite me why don't you have parties
and i'm
like i would if you asked what
that's not how invites go you have lived
there for years now we have not been
there one time
i've been there plenty of times not
really one time
no plenty but you already said you don't
invite people so then she did it the
right way
i need to emphasize that she un it was
uninvitedly
how did i lose that one i could have
sworn i was gonna be right
oh you're always gonna lose you can't
win you cannot ever
not with joe's brain okay wait i want to
talk about my house okay yeah i would be
a basic ass [ __ ] and i just want it to
be like abstract [ __ ]
no the basic part is i just want it to
all be like different shades of pink
with a bunch of [ __ ] glitter and
rhinestones all over the place so where
does bart live
in this mountain oh right right in his
backyard like paris hilton's dream
castle
oh yeah that's what i picture so like in
my version like steve still lives there
he just doesn't have any jurisdiction
over all my trap doors and all things
woody you have trap doors you said in my
house yeah well like in my dream house
you have a trap door yeah like trap
doors like different rooms like yeah
like
bookshelves like whatever yeah no i will
never get lost but what if you like it
malfunctions and you're just like
i'm trapped in my own track i have
emergency systems
oh okay okay you thought it through you
thought you thought what are you getting
oh my house would be a [ __ ] wu-tang
temple oh
what does that mean like like [ __ ]
wu-tang clan all outside of it so the
outside is oh
that's the rap crew like the actual the
kung fu movie right
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no the
rappers are like from new york like
east east coast oh the wu tank i'll
allow it
in the guest house how [ __ ] sick
would that be in the guest house
what's the theme like what are they all
about other like then rap you don't know
i do but i don't i don't know like no
it'd be the [ __ ] logo on the outside
would be
the whole look so it's a w want
the pool to not just be a pool it goes
like through the house it goes like
different like it goes everywhere you
could get
anywhere in the house through the lazy
river yes
it's like atlanta when they went you
know how they go everybody got a cool
house but then this is
so this is something cool about my house
you know that tick tock yeah and then
they go under
oh they come out the stairs and then
they come up the other side
and it goes in the house
yeah i said that's how you get robbed
what the [ __ ] you duped it you do this
again
yeah you go down there and then you go
up and you say doesn't your gun stop
working if it's wet or something
depends on the gun she got you you could
put it in a little little a koozie
you put in a little koozie it's got to
be an amphibious robber you zip you zip
lock it and then you get on the other
side you open it you pull it out of the
ziplock bag
wait a second freeze
it's like [ __ ] the back broke oh wet i
want an entire room to look like the
inside of a [ __ ] genie bottle too
oh that's tired like an eye dream down
dried gym in the morning yeah like i
don't know i've seen one of my trapdoor
rooms
you swear oh yeah it's a feather room
i'm in it's a pillow room and it has
like
feathers and pillows and it's for
[ __ ] right it's [ __ ] sucking no
it's for meditating oh i heard it's
pretty meditative to [ __ ] suck
yeah yeah that's what i hear you can
[ __ ] suck me yes this [ __ ] year
[ __ ] sucks yeah that's true
[Laughter]
that was a good one yeah yeah she did it
[Music]
you